hello the internet and welcome to this
joyous video
I'm extremely because I am out of
opinion yeah so perspective we've got
some of these can you guess what we're
gonna do with them no not on YouTube
that's filthy we're gonna do the condom
showing yeah yeah I've seen this done
many times on the Internet
sometimes people put in a little bit of
sliver but I've never seen it really
really slow I don't even know what
happens you know
it's just one second is there and then
the Nexus route silence hello don't get
it well thanks to the Phantom we'll
figure it out we'll learn something
together
yeah Johnny science you'll have to Nora
but look at the size of these things
its massive just made me feel very
inadequate the person though these exist
good lord
you'll be used to host a flip for Johnny
B yeah yeah what was on your head last
time doesn't it ever not like yeah this
isn't it's where this video is like a
combination of our original Johnny head
video yes I was handed a swim cap video
just sort of combining both of our
videos and that's what you get hey so
when do I breathe in count of three
yeah one dude
[Applause]
[Music]
there's nice actually really yeah was it
likely there it's like a little water
pillow for your head we like your face
you just that could you breathe no oh
you obviously you couldn't breathe but
it's comfy and let's slap your face
around to my face well let your next
beer my next yeah
[Music]
you
you know
[Music]
I'm amazed at how many videos stuffed
tightly wrapped around your head why do
I always end up vanilla it just enough
as well alright final challenge
well town as weird as it is to say I
actually learned something from them
yeah so I didn't know what happened and
now I do I get it I get it now yeah it's
like you're not in there with the water
it's layer of condom and then the war
and then the other layer of condom so
you're actually dry on the inside yeah
when I started this I was scared of so
you know drowning or something just
getting a repeat last night yeah
basically yeah well I hope you enjoyed
that video feel free to follow us on
Twitter you can buy a shirt and if you
love slo-mo and if you think we are okay
you can subscribe and we will love you
for it slow mo guys slow mo guys